hey guys how's it going today we're in
Washington DC Jenna where are we
we're in Washington DC you just done it
right then we had a red-eye flight and
if you don't know what that is that's
where you basically fly overnight to get
to your Hillman to check your seat back
pocket for any personal items like
tablets and cell phone we got in so
early this morning we made it to Dulles
I thought that this was a lot closer
that it was but clearly my planning is
never never that good we're about 45
minutes away from where we need to be
clot you've got a clot I think I
actually made my body is swollen
I can't hold my camera up me and it was
a terrible flight our seats didn't
recline no sleep
I've also never be one of those people
to bring a pillow on a plane and this
time I did and it was the best thing
I've ever done
mine made no difference actually the
time we're not bringing the neck pillow
hurt me
Oh cuz I was on the I it's okay we're
here we're gonna get coffee I'm gonna
get pop it on a positive note as Jenna
said we're here actually precedential
actually president roll my god what
Jenna likes to have it the TV on once
you go to sleep it causes us all issues
with my roommate Wow it's almost like
time to like wake up Oh what about the
astronaut ice cream um if I tell it fast
we're going to the Air and Space Museum
and here's the bad part 8:30 a.m. to
5:30 p.m.
it's hold on
oh god I gotta tweet pull I up with
every all the time 373 41 oh my gosh we
got a go we woke up at two o'clock and
the museum closes at 5:30 we're gonna
make our way downtown
we're on Pennsylvania Avenue right now
we tried to find a Starbucks but this is
closer so we're at Ruger's bagels okay
start off my kingdom
it's looking good Hey Wow Wow child I'm
having breakfast at 3 p.m. I'm exhausted
Jenna I feel like I'm dying I thought I
was gonna shake you to wake up I was
kept sleeping but I have to get to the
Air and Space Museum
I'm gonna try the holiday spice flight
back plus flap what wait I have white
let's go yeah like I didn't say anything
wait a minute
cuz it's a free admission just want our
taxes goes well god I'm getting blown
away let's just show this coffee
my holiday flat white okay we made it
got yelled at for not even entering the
building with a drink and then I had a
little stick on my camera and they made
me put it away so no tripods and no
coffee
okay we have an hour and a half and the
planetarium show starts at 4:00 so let
maybe we should see that do you think
it's long it did we should have just oh
no do we have to buy a ticket
we do we've to buy a ticket hopefully we
could buy it to get there oh look at the
store big boy I'm gonna buy myself a new
spin on this one there's a planetarium
store after domine please look I see the
freeze-dried ice cream this is why she
looks like so we will have to should a
snack ever there's no snacks or drink
lots or drink run water over are you
saying you want to sit you pick I don't
know Sarah
sit over time to see the show brightest
young stars in the south cluster lit and
heated this pocket with in its birth
clap jenna is extremely upset because
she is question question tiny follow-up
mint chocolate chip ice cream
hey Jen can you name all the planets I
have so many questions okay so um don't
respond Mercury Venus Earth Mars Jupiter
Saturn Uranus Neptune and Pluto I think
it's still planet I'm not sure is it
back or this Pluto a planet again
oh boy this is really old how does this
fly doesn't and hydrators this is
actually better than what we didn't just
fly
it smells old get me out huh see lots of
quick trip to the Aerospace Museum
they're closing now so we have to go but
he saw a lot of things quite quickly
I enjoyed the planetarium show so much
now we're to go and don't know what
we're gonna do
so stay tuned we are right next door to
the National Treasury which we is
originally all I thought it was the
White House because it was white looked
like the White House so it's got to be
the White House right wrong there it is
guys sister I can take a picture of you
in front of the National Treasury okay
let me get close enough they won't know
yeah well I'm sorry
full dinners here yes yes guys look I'm
wearing my ear pods can you believe it
I've been working on forming them to my
ear my technique is pushing them so hard
into my ear until I feel excruciating
pain and that's how I know that I'm
making a change I'm making a change in
my body by my injuring myself make that
stay here do not try that at home I'm
not actually doing that but I did plan
on telling Matt that Jenna told me that
I should tell Matt that I am using
excruciating pain techniques to make
them form to my ear and also I'd like to
like lay down and like add heat so that
it starts melting into my think he would
believe you oh honey I'm not doing any
of those things Jen what do we have for
dinner well we have a lovely show up
lovely tater tots Oh lovely underneath
that is probably my lovely child pasta
my smell it underneath that is a salad I
got a Santa so I got a Caesar salad
let's see holds your kid pasta here's
Gemma's pasta take a kiss
I think that brings this vlog just oh
god haha right there
where oh I think I'm gonna attach a tile
to them so that I will never lose them
the tile is the same size as this well
that brings today's vlog to a close I
was going to make this in a two-part
vlog but I want to have the white house
be its own separate one which we are
doing that tomorrow the 24 hour vlog
which it was supposed to be in three
parts of 2016 is going crazy it took me
12 hours to export and I'm either going
to be posting that on Friday or Saturday
so stay tuned I can't wait it's gonna be
so cool so I'll see you guys then bye
see it the White House distance Leto's
entry for us but does not make things on
Netflix I didn't find anything to wear
tomorrow I think we have bigger issues
than what I need to wear in the White
House that's a whole nother story
2017 is the year of not waking up early